congressman Sean Duffy is a Republican
from the state of Wisconsin he joins us
in Congress thanks very much for coming
doctor so I I don't think there's ever
been anything like this I can't remember
members of a community calling for the
resignation of the chairman ever why do
what because it's the death of shame
here Tucker you have Adam Schiff who you
read on the committee that I mean this
is a serious committee I mean you
usually don't know the members of this
committee you don't know the chairman of
this committee because that's right they
kind of work under the cover of darkness
and they're supposed to keep America
safe they're focused on Iran in North
Korea and and in China and terrorists
and it's very bipartisan working to keep
Americans safe but you have Adam Schiff
out there who's not taken the Bob Muller
report who he said was a gold standard
he was gonna take seriously and except
he's not accepting it he's out there
raising money he's part of the resist
movement he's leading there was this
movement and he's trying to do undo the
election from 2016 and and if I look at
this if you look at all the commentators
all the crazy commentators that got it
wrong even look at you know clapper and
and Comey and Brennan all used to work
in the intelligence community but they
left that community and they went on TV
and in spewed the lives of Russia
clusion the only one who was still
getting daily briefings her daily job
was intelligence was Adam shifting here
to get his intelligence briefings and
then go to the media and lie about that
intelligence to to promote the story of
Russia collusion and you know what he's
lost the confidence of the Congress he's
lost the confidence of the American
people and he needs to step down because
he's not trusted anymore
and we need to bring this committee back
to a one that works for the American
people give up the Russia occlusion and
and start to keep us safe and one less
point talk of if I could I'm so proud of
the American system you know you had the
Democrat Party you had Hollywood you
have big technology you're the liberal
media all trying to take down Donald
Trump and we should be celebrating
tonight that the American system
actually works
an investigation happened and you have
Donald Trump who is for the most part
exonerated not charged with Russia
occlusion because the American system is
alive and well today in our country it's
just if you tell me the earth is flat
and I show you a picture of its
curvature and you still believe it's
flat it says something about your
capacity for a reason so true all right
Thank You congressman thanks very much
so